today we are playing a drinking game on
the podcast and we're playing never will
I ever and it's a game where we're
talking about all the mistakes that we
made when we were selling our company
and saying never will we ever make this
mistake again and if you ever want to
sell a company or you've sold a company
if you sold a company you're going to be
able to relate some of these mistakes
I'm sure if you want to someday sell
your company it's good to listen to so
that you don't have to pay the same
price that we did and make these
mistakes so go ahead grab a drink we're
playing never will I ever
[Music]
today we are talking about how to sell a
company and in fact we're talking about
how not to sell a company these are
mistakes that we made uh selling our
company so Sam sold the hustle to
HubSpot and a big deal sold to a public
company um I've had two exits now under
my belt and I've sold one to a big
company Amazon and one one to a small
group of private buyers and every time
you sell your company you learn a bunch
of lessons but we're going to make this
fun so if you've ever played the
drinking game never have I ever we have
a new drinking game for you MFM style
right this is never will I ever and
never will I ever is a game where we say
never will I ever do blank again um
because we made so many mistakes we made
these mistakes so you don't have to we
died so you don't have to here and if
you listen to this you're going to be a
lot smarter when it comes to selling
your company Sam are you ready to play
the game what are you drinking what's
your drink I mean I only have a little
bit left here but I got some greens the
morning I'm looking a little athletic
and I got some greens not sponsored but
you know send me a free box yeah now
save you 80 bucks a month um dude I have
I have a ton of it I drink it once in a
while it's really hard to stomach for me
you like you could just drink that plain
I love it plain and I love that it
doesn't taste that great because to me I
don't want my health [__] tasting good
right I don't like my hot people to be
funny too I don't like when things that
are not supposed to go together go
together all right that guy Matt r that
comedian no too good looking I'm not
watching that special number one on
Netflix no thank at all well you're
pretty funny what does that make you
pretty
ugly as the world should
be um all right what how do we want to
go about this we have a bunch of points
here which one you want let's start with
the the most straightforward thing
okay uh so never will I ever you both we
both have this one ignore qsbs I'll
drink to that
yes now explain when you say ignore qsbs
what happened here qsbs for those who
don't know I didn't know about it until
like a year before I sold my friend Jack
Smith told me about it qsbs I'm going to
try and state the law here but it says
so it stands for qu qualified small
business stock qsbs protects up to 10
10x of your investment from long-term
capital gains taxes of $10 million or
10x your uh initial investment what that
means and a lot of people only pay
attention to the $10 million thing so
with qsbs how long do you have to hold
it your stock is five years yes so you
hold a a small business stock so a
privately held company that's a a C Corp
and you have to hold it for 10 or five
years and it has to be valued originally
or the assets of the company which is
the value has to be 50 million or less
you hold it for 5 years and you can
save1 million in capital G the first 10
million when you sell so like let's say
you sell for 10 all 10 would be taxfree
at a federal level and many states also
honor qsbs not California but many
states also do so you could walk away
paying zero in taxes if you sold for $10
million which is remarkable or now
here's the or part that a lot of people
forget or you can save up to 10 times
your investment whichever is greater the
10 times or the 10 million now what that
means is let's say that theoretically
you start as an LLC or you don't have a
your company isn't value but let's say
you start as an LLC and you convert to a
C Corp and when you convert you value
your company and it usually has to be
done by a third party so it has to be
reasonable you value your company let's
say you're doing uh 15 million in
Revenue let's say you're doing 20
million in revenue and you say great I
think we're a $40 million company you
get third party that does it so you can
save 10 times $40 million in taxes $400
million that's a $400 million tax shield
right there yes and I know friends that
are doing this now this this this this
law a lot of people don't know about it
it's maybe besides real some real estate
laws for tax savings in real estate it's
probably the greatest thing there is it
it's better better you think it's better
it's better than real estate because in
real estate you have let's say uh
depreciation or the 1031 exchange these
are great but they're deferrals whereas
this is not a deferral this is simply
you just have a you know you have a
exclusion on 100% of your gains up to
some number so it is way better than a
deferral is way better than real estate
I was talking to a real estate guy
yesterday and I said I have the greatest
tax thing that no real estate guy has
what are you talking about real estate's
the most tax advantage I say yes but you
don't have qsbs because real estate is
not eligible for qsbs there only certain
types of businesses can do it but like
like Sam saying you could stack it so
for example what some people do they
have qsbs for themselves but it's per
tax return so you could do it for
yourself you can create trusts for your
kids and give each of them equity and
then each trust gets a $10 million
exclusion in addition to your own so you
could have you know I was joking around
with a qsbs guy and he's like yeah if
you have three kids I can get you I can
get you 40 million 50 million in qsbs
and I was like I was like oh this kid I
have you know this is next kid you I'm
going to have this is this is just a
walking qsbs Shield here like this is
awesome and uh it used to be that it was
that mean that your kid when they're but
were your your kids at the age of 18
have say in control of your business
with they're 18 I mean you ex exited by
them by then right like but they're
going to have but maybe not but they're
going to have a just a small Equity say
they're not going to get the majority
right like you're just giving them
enough so that they have a shield they
have like you they have less less attx
and you you while they're minors you
control the state you can always you
know sure I don't know I don't think
what a lot of people having is like
little kids that 18 years later are like
succession hostile taking over like the
company as they band together I don't I
don't think that's the that's the thing
to worry about and we'll wrap this one
up by with there's a big asteris here
which is this I don't like calling it a
loophole because that first of all I
hate that word loophole because
loopholes are good loopholes are legal
like when someone says a loophole I'm
like okay but you're trying to spin this
negative but like you're just following
the law TR tie in a shoe without a
loophole
huh yeah yeah it's essential or people
say shortcuts they're like that's that's
a shortcut I'm like well I love
shortcuts if I can arrive at the same
destination just as safe and faster than
a long cut I'm taking the shortcut uh
but so this loophole there's an asteris
here because I think two years ago it
was it was up to vote if they were going
to a it and the idea was they might make
it only 50% or so they reduce it by um
half uh I don't know if this is going to
be in play for how much longer this is
not like real estate where it's going to
last forever right right yeah it it's
but it's it's been out for a while um
and it's it's amazing especially in the
in the tech
industry I can't find this client info
have you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a
CRM platform so it shares its data
across every application every team can
stay aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
or dueling databases HubSpot grow better
all right so my turn never will I
ever just shut down a company without
trying to sell so well drink yeah have a
drink for that I uh before I sold before
my first exit I had built many companies
many products before that and they all
had reached some version of like you
know an outcome some really had no no
momentum some had like some momentum but
not breakout and it was either wasn't
worth our time or it wasn't able to get
funding or
whatever I specifically remember one app
that we made that was if you remember
bitmoji we had basically made an app
that was like way better than bitmoji it
just like and bitmoji was giving you an
like a a personal ad little character
for yourself that would be in these and
then it would give you like kind of like
these stickers that were in funny like
positions or phrases we had made an app
that was even better making the world a
better place one emoji at a time exactly
emojis are emojis are one of the
greatest products ever right self-
expression there um so you we had made
an app that created a character of you
um and then you could and then you could
type any word you could just type
hashtag whatever uh boogie down and it
would make your character boogie down
and we had every like whatever you could
think of like you could put you could
say hashtag single ladies and it would
dress your character up like Beyonce
right away doing the Single Ladies dance
like whatever you could think of we
would we had because we would just every
day we would rank the top tagged term
and our artists would create like
hundreds of these per day so very
quickly we had tens of thousands of
combinations it was really fun because
you could just type something and just
to see does it do it or not and people
did this we got half a million people to
download the app in the first month they
were just pounding like tons of these
little stickers it didn't have great
longevity but it had this like amazing
novelty factor and we were trying to do
it as its own messaging app which was
too hard like people wanted WhatsApp
they wanted Facebook Messenger they
wanted all these
things and I wrote this blog post called
myund million dollar mistake because we
took that and we said well this is not
really sticky as a messenger it's not
big enough where you're going to get all
your friends to switch and and start
texting you here people love the
character they love these stickers we
don't want to build a sticker company so
I guess we'll just crumble it all up and
just Kobe and just throw it away and um
that was so dumb in retrospect what we
should have done is taken that little
app to all of the existing messaging
companies and be like hey this feature
is unbelievable building this is not
easy we've already built it we've proven
that people really like to do this look
how many like the average person is
doing 60 of these um you know just buy
this and put this into your keyboard and
shortly after bitmoji sold for $100
million do to Snapchat doing exactly
that because they they couldn't make it
as a standalone app either and um I have
no idea why our Instinct was just to
like just pivot just turn it off and
pivot versus like take 30 days and have
like five conversations even if it
doesn't go through like you owe it to
yourself after after you know nine
months of hard work or a year of hard
work uh and creativity on something so
never will I ever just shut it down you
said we got a 100 or sorry we got
500,000 downloads in 60 days and had a
brief moment at number one on the charts
before falling into
mediocrity uh how much could you have
sold this for easily tens of millions
easily like you know you think it either
wasn't GNA sell at all because there's
only like eight buyers for this there
was like eight me messaging app that
were major at the time it was like line
and kick and
um you know WhatsApp and Facebook
Messenger Snapchat there's you know
there's eight players that like could
benefit from something like this and
either it just wasn't going to sell at
all but like that's actually unlikely
there's a price there's a kind of like a
price for every buyer um the hard part
would have been or team wouldn't have
wanted to go with the acquisition and so
we would have had to
like either try to just sell the tech
which is really hard or sell the whole
company including the team and then
disband for a year then come back
together and we uh just you know we
didn't but we the thing is we didn't
even really get to that point like we
should have gone and seen what our
options were right like in in poker if
you've already paid the blind well just
see the Flop maybe you maybe something
good will come out of it and we didn't
do that did you by the way you're if you
Google $100 million mistake Shan Perry
there's uh you have a medium blog uh
you've got a lot of good posts here so
if you're listening go check it out did
you not and this might bring me to my my
point did you not sell because you're a
main investor didn't give a [__] no it
it literally just didn't come up it's
not like we had a conversation and one
one side said yes one side said no and
we debated it and then one side said no
I have the voting control hell we didn't
even think about it we just moved we
literally had lunch and then we just
moved on like it was just like it's the
worst types of mistakes the worst types
of mistakes are the ones where you
didn't even really explore the
possibilities you didn't even ask
yourself what could I do here you just
sort of quickly glossed over it didn't
uh didn't even give it the thought to
make a decision it was a non-decision
decision
that's like your third or fourth or
fifth multi like T multi- tens of
millions of dollars mistake the first
one being not joining stripe as employee
30 or 50 or something like that and not
selling this app and I think I think you
might have a dude I'm I'm Shooter
McGavin and Happy Gilmore when he says I
eat pieces of [__] like you for
breakfast and then Happy Gilmore goes
you eat pieces of [__] for breakfast
that's me i' I've made mistakes more
expensive than your net worth it's like
you've made mistakes like this it's like
yeah multiple multiple
um all right here I've got one never
will I ever act desperate you have on
here you will only have one option that
is the way that not act desperate that
is one way but when I was building my
company I wanted an exit so badly like
give me an analogy on the spot analogy
you wanted an exit as bad as like a 12
like when I was 12 years 12 years old
and like a cute girl like you know like
complimented my braces it's like I want
to close this so badly I'm emotionally
invested if you don't like me no one
will like me and I'm a piece of [__] I
was so desperate I had all of my
personal uh net worth my emotional net
worth tied into this exit and I acted
like a little [__] and one of the ways
not to do this is to have multiple
options that's the easiest most tactical
one is to have lots of options the
second one is you just don't you you
basically to act like a hot girl you're
like look I don't care like I'm going to
be fine regardless and I remember there
was one point do you track your like
your finances somewhere I have like a a
spreadsheet and I remember one day I
just added like 10 million like you have
like an other account so you can link
all your accounts and I just had other
and I just manually typed in $10 million
and I would stare at that for like six
months and it actually helped me believe
that I already had it and so I was a
little bit less desperate but I remember
being desperate and when you are
desperate you have zero power and when
you have zero power that is the worst
part to be in when you negotiate and the
the best part when you can negotiate is
to walk away and the and or to be able
to walk away and to be able to walk away
you typically just don't give a [__] so
you're just like passionate about
whatever you're doing and you don't need
the money or you have other options and
I remember being desperate in that just
like to that 12-year-old girl who was
into me Aaron uh you know like they
could sense it they could they could
smell the the the the hormones on you
like anyone could any hot girl could
tell when you're being desperate they
could tell what a confident man is like
and I was not a confident
man can you put your retainer back in
please it's the same thing right yeah
the um you nailed it in that last bit
which is the rules the rules of a NE of
negotiating when you are when you're
trying to sell your company number one
the most important rule is you must be
okay if no deal happens meaning not just
like I'll I'll be all right like you
know like a funeral has happened but you
the you know option one should always be
we do no deal and we're totally fine I
would love to keep going and whether
that's true or not there is should be no
grieving you convince yourself that
that's true that you don't want your
options to just be offer number one or
offer number two because guess what
offer number One's Gonna have some hair
on it offer number two is gonna be a
little shaky maybe fall through you're
going to start to feel real desperate
when offer two falls through and now
it's only offer one on the table you
always need the one option on the table
that you can control which is I will
keep running my company it will grow and
just be bigger and better if I keep
going and you have to convince yourself
of that if you want to have a chance in
these negotiations the second rule is in
any negotiation the side that cares the
least wins and so you have to be the one
who needs the deal less than the other
party and so whether that's true or not
it's a mentality you must mentally need
it less than the other side you must
mentally care less than the other side
that this deal goes through exactly as
is if you could do that then you're in
pretty good shape and you know which
deal is the best deal the one that will
actually close that's another huge
learning not all deals are the same the
one that will close to close a deal it's
a really big deal to get an offer and go
through diligence that's not nearly as
big of a deal you and I have both gone
through stuff where the offer was great
and the the people buying were either
disorganized they were [__] they
change their opinion something you want
to do the deal that will close that is
the best deal that that is one of mine
as well I put uh never will I ever go
with the highest offer sounds confusing
like what do you mean why would you not
take the highest offer you want to take
the best offer not the highest offer and
the best offer and the highest offer
have a lot of differences the one of the
differences what you just said
likelihood to actually close will they
do what they say they do they say they
will do um I'll give you a story from
the milk Road sale we had a high offer
and then we had a fair offer and at
first we were like hell hell yeah we got
the high offer this is great but they
they did a bunch of weird stuff though
there was some red flags but hey D like
you know like anything else you know
when when something's really attractive
that red flag this starts to look just
like a it's like is that maroon actually
maybe that's maybe that's orange you
know like it's not so red you you start
to overlook and talk yourself out of a
bunch of things right so like what was
one of those red flags can you say they
had a lawyer that would jump on the call
that refused to ever turn his camera on
had no LinkedIn sent us a document that
was like the term sheet that was like
our lawyer was like there's no way a
lawyer wrote this and we were like okay
it's probably not good that their lawyer
is not a lawyer but um we don't
understand also why why they would not
have a lawyer it's like it's this guy's
friend he says he's a lawyer it's like
so strange it's like you know they're
not like scammers but
is like can you just turn your camera on
and uh you know like it was weird uh it
was just like a little bit weird that
was like one I think they sent you money
didn't they then you were sent money we
we went down the we took the offer and
um there was a time to close but the
again one of the stupid things they did
they wrote the offer as when we signed
the the term sheet which is not the deal
is not closed you sign the term sheet uh
they wired us all the money they had to
wire us all the money on day one which
again was like are these guys idiots why
are they doing that that's not how this
is supposed to go um but we were like
well I guess we're getting money so like
what what do you know and it was during
that kind of closing period that we
started to get a little sketched out and
said look I don't think this is the
right deal for us maybe we should just
go back to options one we'll just keep
running our company we don't have to do
this deal so we wired back millions of
dollars voluntarily because we had made
the mistake of going with the highest
offer first and the best offer is a
combination of it's likely to close I'll
tell you a funny story about that um the
people involved are high quality and
they're people you want to be around
because it's not a uh sort of hit it and
quit it you're never going to see these
people again like business even if your
deal is kind of like you walk away clear
like I don't know the business world is
actually kind of small you run into
people they now own your company your
brand like you don't want it in the
wrong hands you'd rather do business
with great people who you might do more
business with in the future um which is
what we ended up doing so the best offer
is different now let me tell you a story
about uh about um likelihood to close so
we get this High offer and we're
comparing the high offer with the fair
offer and I call uh bology and people
know bology you know he one of the
smartest people on earth I call bologi I
said bology what would you do if you
were me and he's like well that's a
higher offer um but let me ask you a
question have a of course like
intelligent people can get to the heart
of the issue right away like he just
like a metal detector just new and he
goes are you negotiating these on the
same time scale and I was like I don't
know what that means he's like who did
you talk to First and how far how long
have you been talking to them and how
long have you talking to the high offer
I said well I've talked to the fair
offer way earlier we've negotiated it
renegotiated it they've done diligence
and the high offer is new blah BL blah
he goes okay so this is not the real
offer and he's like um you need to apply
a discount and I said well what do you
mean and he's like well you you don't
know if this deal is going to close you
don't know if this number is going to
stand you don't know if they're going to
change their mind they say this is all
fresh and a fresh deal is not the real
deal and so he's like you need to just
mentally apply some discount factor for
if this even is going to be the final
offer that gets sent to your bank
account and so I was like okay so like
10% he's like tell me what you know
about this person I told him everything
I know he's like
50% and so we had to cut the offer by
50% mentally to to to you know compare
apples to apples and that was of the
best advice we got was that one piece of
advice so now I always in any deal I
have to ask myself what's the discount
Factor here meaning How likely are they
to close um have they done all their
diligence yet have we already had the
deal have we already negotiated this to
a stalemate where kind of both sides
feel like they've gone as far as they're
willing to go because that's when you
can reduce the discount when we were
selling to HubSpot I remember the just
like I said the the my contact the woman
I was speaking with she sensed weakness
and she sensed uh uh she sensed that I
was in a tough Place emotionally and she
and cuz I was constantly asking her were
sobbing all right what else do you need
where how do how do we move this forward
yeah she could like she could she's like
are are you laying down when you're
talking to me like she just like sense
that I was like laying on the floor and
and the difference between what you did
and what I did was two things one I sold
to a a public company which meant
basically the decision maker was not the
CEO or the owner of the company it was
the person who reported to the person
who reported to the person who who
reported to the person it was like four
you know ladders down probably the
decision maker the CEO was probably like
they just saw it on their like board
meeting every once in a while like you
know quarterly and they're like okay
cool whatever now can we talk about
important stuff and this woman she was
like
look we don't care about you you know
she basically said she's like our
company is worth like 20 or 30 billion
and this is a rounding air for us our
reputation matters more than than this
little deal and it would hurt it would
hurt our reputation more than the than
the cost of this deal in order to dick
you around if we say we're going to do
something we're going to do something
now shut up and relax that's basically
like what she was saying to me and I
remember feeling that like I feel so
much better and uh so I think there's a
difference between selling to like like
selling a small business to a soul
proprietor or to a PE company or to a
really large large strategic company I
think the way that you deal with those
sellers is different or buyers is
different I'll tie that in I have never
will I ever never will I
ever assume the person I'm talking to is
the person who's buying my company so
this
is when we sold to Twitch uh which is
owned by Amazon I'm talking to Corp Dev
as very easy to think I I'm assuming
you're talking about somebody in corp
Dev yeah in corp Dev she this lady was
wonderful she was like my therapist for
three months right and Corp Dev is very
helpful they're they're the they're the
router they're the project manager of
any acquisition but they are not the
decision maker and actually the thing
you described I actually think is not
that true meaning I actually do think
there is a decision maker they are
pretty high up it's either the CEO or
it's the the VP or the SVP who runs like
you know or somebody in the SE Suite who
like matters to sign off on a on a
transaction of of of you know a multi8
figure transaction that's not it's
actually
not uh it actually the decision actually
does lad up but by Design these
companies design it so you're never
actually going to get to talk to that
person because they need good cop bad
cop they need the person whose job is it
to move the transaction along or find
out information and then that person
can't actually be the one who's
negotiating with you they're going to be
like cool I'll go back and find out and
that layer those layers of bureaucracy
are actually a huge negotiating
advantage that a startup typically
doesn't have um unless you're working
with bankers and whatnot where you where
you do have an intermediary that's able
to do that for you and so one of the
most important things you got to figure
out is who's actually buying this
company it's not a company that buys a
company there is a person in a company
who needs something for their job and
you have to figure out who is that
person and what is the fire under their
ass you know what is the thing that you
know are they in trouble for their job
and they need to do something because
the competitor is getting ahead are they
super strategic and they had a dinner
with with somebody and they they had an
epiphany and now they're they're Steve
Jobs they're a Visionary and they're
trying to make that Vision come true you
need to fit that story like um you know
you have to figure out who is that
person in the company and what is the
fire under their ass if you ever if you
want to have a chance of being able to
sell a company because you're selling to
that person that champion alone not to a
multi-billion dollar Corporation right
and and so the buyer really matters and
understanding what motivates them a lot
of times the people in corp Dev they
just want to keep their jobs and they
want to look good and so as a seller you
have to sell a company and you have to
make them look great you have to make it
easy for them to look wonderful you you
have such different incentives they are
just trying to not fumble the bag you
are trying to get your first bag and you
are going to behave totally differently
and you're going to Value different
things and if they ever said to me
something like oh this is kind of a
rounding error or like you know this is
we're huge this is not this is not a
this you know this is a small small
piece of it I'd be like cool round up
the price just went up 10 million then
right like you know if if this money
don't matter to you it matters a hell
every dollar of this matters to me and
so maybe we have the price wrong
actually then uh let's get the price
right before we we continue all right
like that is um and by the way you saw
this uh we just renegotiated our deal
with HubSpot and like you know without
going into the you know the guts
everything matter everything mattered
and you saw how I approached that me and
you have very different approaches to
negotiation what did you see or describe
describe that so this is like a Midwest
value thing which is if if I order a
steak and you send me out a pizza I'm
just going to shut up and eat it and I
ain't going to complain the way that you
did this steak tastes
different yeah yeah I love my steak with
mozzarella and uh pasta sauce this is
exactly how I like it you handled it
differently and I and frankly I I I that
was uh one of that was a an example when
I learned from you I think you said
something great you said um whoever can
be most uncomfortable will win and you
needled these [__] guys for
everything and in my head I was like
what why who gives a [__] and you're
like this word needs to be that and I'm
like what are you doing and and you were
like it all matters it all is really
important and frankly you got your way
uh at least for the big important stuff
and when you got your way I got my way
too to get the negotiation done both
sides have to get their way but you have
to figure out what really matters to
them and what really matters to us and
those two things are not going to line
up and you need um like Sam Alman you
he's he's all in the news right now and
he said something great about
negotiation uh he goes I am not
interested in binary negotiations
there's nothing interesting there where
it's just a number and you want it to be
lower and I want it to be higher that's
just a tug that's just a tug of war
that's like you know that's not
interesting that's not a sport it's like
slap fighting versus MMA right like the
slap league is literally just one guy
standing there with no defense and one
guy's gonna SM slap him as hard as he
can it's kind of interesting to see but
like it doesn't have the same uh it's
not as satisfying to to to the
sophisticated Barbarian like us who
likes you know UFC instead and so um the
sophisticated Barbarian cares about a u
a nonzero sum negotiation and so it's
like how do I give them what what's that
French word jqa what is that what is
that all right am I saying that right
there's an art there and so you have to
figure out what are the things they
really care about that I only kind of
care about one of the things I really
care about that they only kind of care
about how do we all get what we want in
order for this to work um but you're
right that I was willing to be more
uncomfortable than you or maybe most
people just because I don't know this is
our baby and this is like one line item
for them but this is like our this is
like the basis of what we do and it has
potential to be like such an awesome
part of our lives like uh you know I
have to get this right this is my kid
it's like you know my kid versus uh you
know how my teach how when they go to
school how a teacher is going to teach
treat my kid like they care but not the
same way I do about my baby right it's
different there's levels to that and so
uh yeah you know the the party that's
willing to be more uncomfortable
generally will win or the way my dad
taught me was the more stubborn person
wins in any negotiation uh can I tell
you a dad negotiation story yeah so I
worked with my dad for about um nine
months I think in my life and I I I'm
really happy and your dad does
everything right he's like like he does
projects he started as engineer lowly
engineer and he has like you know he is
like office space or like Dunder Mifflin
or something like he was sitting in his
cubicle and he kept getting patents so
his wall had like 22 patents on the wall
um but his salary stayed the same and
he's like how come like you know this
like the guy who dresses up nice he
works with me for six months I get this
patent he gets promoted I stay here like
wait am I in the wrong job so it took
him 10 years to figure that out he's
like maybe I should move to the business
side he works at a he works at BP for
like 30 40 years and he finally like
leaves and he does then he started doing
more entrepreneurial things one of which
was uh we both worked together in this
company in Australia and and um when we
were working there I got to see my dad
in action and like it's so funny like
you see your dad at home and Dad's at
home are just like these like totally
different creatures when they're like
done with work for the day I had to see
him like interacting with other people
especially for an immigrant Dad it's
like it's like oh you have this level of
Polish why at home do you turn into just
like a caveman um and so I got to see
him just act totally differently and one
of the things that happened was they uh
we were negotiating with uh this other
party the other party was was this slick
talking Australian guy who literally
looked like Leonardo DiCaprio This Guy's
on like the Australian CNBC every week
and he's super polished just an amazing
talker and I just think oh my God my
dad's I'm gonna have to get watch my dad
get beat up in this negotiation this
guy's like Mr Mr Charisma Mr Smooth
everybody already loves him the decision
maker loves him and they want one thing
we want another uh my dad's you know
this PO you know this Indian guy who can
barely you know he forgets to add the
connecting words and sentences he's just
going to get walked all over this this
thing and then they walk in and this
guy's got like binders of like you know
spreadsheets presentation like he's got
everything prepared my dad has nothing
doesn't even have like a pen on him and
the guy that guy makes his case first he
kind of passes it around he's like
here's what I think we should do and I
want to run the project and give me the
funding and here's what we're going to
do with it it's going to be great
everybody's like this is super well put
together thank you so much blah blah
blah and um it's my dad's turn and my
dad basically kind of like refuses to
speak and then he starts to speak and
I'm like where's The Logical argument
he's not like using any logic he's just
saying no I'm not doing that I want to
do this and I'm not doing it if we're
doing it that way and then they're like
you know but Raj we have like you know
this plan it makes sense look I know
you're not getting the exact Equity you
want you're not getting to run it but
like this guy will run it but you this
makes sense right and my dad's just like
foot on the table he's like I'm just
telling you right now
it's not happening never not happening
and I'm like what are you doing like
you're not even backing up your words
you're just saying no and you're just
refusing you look like such a stubborn
idiot and he just acted the fool for
like an
hour and uh they were like this is going
nowhere and they walked out and I was
like dude you blew it and he's like no
that went perfectly and I was like what
do you mean and he's like uh he's like
oh I could never compete with that guy
he's like you know super charismatic and
he he has all the facts on his side I
was like so what's your your plan is
what he's like oh I'm just going to the
most powerful word negotiation no he's
like I'm just gonna say no I'm not doing
it I'm not doing it that way and I'm not
gonna I don't need to explain why I'm
not doing it and actually I'm offended
that it's going this way I'm pissed off
and actually I might blow this whole
thing up and uh he's like you know I
only have one piece of Leverage which is
that they need me to play along in
whatever we're going to do here like
it's gonna be hard for them to replace
me in this thing so I'm just going to
say no and I learned so much that day he
told me he goes the more stubborn guy in
the room did they come back yeah of
course come back they came back and in
fact the exact opposite happened by the
end of the whole thing we negotiated
this deal and like you know there's just
kind of like okay let's take a break
we'll go get the yeah yeah we what were
you doing I was there I was where's the
moral support and um they leave the room
to take like a break or they're printing
out the papers or whatever and my dad
turns to the middleman guy he goes so
how what do you think he goes he goes I
think we're playing poker but all the
chips are on your side of the table now
and actually my dad made a mistake which
was that he negotiated it way too hard
and took all the value in the end and
then they then they realized it and they
were like you know what we let this
stubborn idiot take the whole thing the
whole enchilada like No And they went
back to no and we actually ended up more
like at a 50-50 deal but if if he had
just given a little bit back you always
want to kind of give back at the end uh
where they feel like they have something
to lose he took it so far he wanton them
go so badly that they at the end had
nothing to lose in the negoti in closing
the deal they're like well what do I
have to gain by closing this deal
nothing it's just all all the values
going to him at this point and so he had
taken a little too far but I'll never
forget that idea that you know the in
any negotiation it is not the side that
has the better argument or the more or
more logic it's Whoever has more
leverage number one and then within that
you're that's like the the the substance
and then you have the style and the
style is whoever's a little more
stubborn and a little more crazy a
little more irrational that is uh to
your advantage in a negotiation we got
to have your mom and dad on the Pod I
think we we've heard a lot of stories
about them um all right I'll do we'll do
water two more uh here's a really easy
and simple one never will I ever be
disorganized and I'll give you an
example of that we changed payrolls like
three different times it was like Gusto
and then ADP and then like zenefits and
then Rippling because Rippling can track
your computers uh like when you give out
computers or Gusto pays two days later
so I can keep the cash for two it was so
stupid and here's why it's so stupid
when you selling a company for 30
million and 300 million it's the same
thing basically as in a lot of times
when you sell a business let's say I
don't know what that threshold is it
could be 10 or 15 million but when you
sell a company for 300 million and 15
million they basically give you this
Excel sheet and it has five pages and
each page has literally 50 bullet points
and each bullet point is a big deal for
example one bullet point will be under
the HR Tab and it will say show me the
payroll for the last five years or show
me um every contractor you've ever hired
yeah add the Contracting agreement you
have with every single contractor
including the confidentiality it's like
H we don't even have that yet like yes
yeah and here's why it's a big deal when
you switch Pay Here's a very specific
example when you if you just use one
payroll that's easy you just click
export that's easy but I didn't and so I
had a and then if you know if it's been
three years you have to call zenefits be
like I don't have access to my account
anymore do you guys even have these
records and I thought this was stupid
and I was like I remember telling Kip
the CMO of HubSpot I was like Kip I used
Fiverr one time I paid $150 out of my
PayPal account I even paid it personally
and he's I was like why does this matter
and he's like well you know I can't hire
B baller 84 on Fiverr because and that
goes against fiverr's terms of service
and that would be like I can't I have to
make sure that everything was by the
book because every little thing matters
and and that made a lot of sense to me
but I was a fool and I was disorganized
I would use PayPal for some stuff every
once in a while I would just venmo
someone I'd be like here's 500 bucks
thanks for the freelance or I wouldn't
track uh confidentiality agreements it
was a [__] mess I used Google drive
to store some stuff Dropbox the store
some it was a mess and I'm telling you
when you're selling a company for what I
sold it for I only had 40 employees and
you can't tell anyone that you're
selling the company so it was basically
me and Edie this woman who worked with
me and we went through all of these
documents to find all of this [__] and
it literally took three months to find
documents that's and three months
working every day for 12 hours today it
is so hard to get all the documents it
is so challenging and you don't want to
give them anything that's messy
otherwise you'll look not buttoned up
and if you look not buttoned up they'll
say what else are you missing or like
are you lying about something and you
need a present things in a really nice
orderly fashion and so start being
organized from day one is really really
important and not like being a Maverick
and being like I'll just here I got 20
bucks I'll pay you for this I'll use
PayPal for this uh like it's a mess well
I got to drink to that because I made
that same mistake no surprise I'm like
the most disorganized guy on Earth and
uh you know I made mistakes like I
thought uh you know hey start up you
guys got to move fast don't waste time
incorporating and getting trademarks and
um doing all that and you know that
could be the difference between
long-term capital Gams and short-term
gains or having to you know explain why
you know the IP is over here but it
should be over here um or you know we
made a mistake of um did you mail in
your 83b uh one year I did and for one
company I just didn't do it and I was
like I was like oh I gotta like go to
the post office and I just didn't do it
now luckily that company failed and I
didn't have to pay the price of that but
like you know in the 83b election
basically but if anybody doesn't know is
like a you can basically get shares in a
company and you can tell the IRS hey tax
me now this year on the gain of these
shares um because I'm gonna exercise
them now it's like $100 I'm gonna
exercise these shares now um tax me you
know so it's like the original strike
price was one cent and then they're
valued at one and a half cents and so
you're like tax me today on that gain so
that I've exerise the shares at this
price so that when I sell I don't have
to uh pay this huge markup on the on the
exercise of the and you only have like
30 or 60 days to mail it in and you
basically literally have to write a
letter is it 90 days you have to write a
letter and you want to like postmark it
and then you want to like you you write
in the letter like send me a receipt of
this it's like a really manual process
and you're like dear IRS please send me
proof that you received this and you
have to store that in your records in
case you all ever get audited and I
think now this like I think there's some
automation around this but yeah I I was
messy about that uh you know I had this
great meeting when I wanted to sell my
company didn't know how and I went and I
met with five people who had sold
multiple companies and I was like okay
hey I don't know what the [__] I'm doing
here um can I explain to you what I'm
currently doing and then you tell me
what I'm doing that which which parts
point out the dumb Parts okay can you do
that because I was like if I just ask
you for your advice who knows what to
say but if I draw you a picture of what
I'm doing and you can point to the ugly
part that'll help me and so that's I did
I had uh lunch with this guy fad and uh
he's the CE of this company called array
now he had sold I think he sold like
five companies or some [__] like that
and um he pointed out two mistakes that
I was making number one he goes uh he's
like oh wow you got like okay you have
an actual offer on the table and I was
like yeah dude it's been so hard such a
long road you know even though it only
been like 40 days when I was like dude
yeah it's just been ups and downs but
finally we're here and I was talking
like I arrived at some destination he
goes he's looked at me he's like this is
not over actually you just reached the
starting line now it's time to Sprint
and and I've repeated that advice to so
many people of now it's time to Sprint
because so many times this happened
let's say you're fundraising for a
company and you spend you know three
months try a fund raise you finally get
money in the bank and you're so happy So
Satisfied your whole body just wants to
relax it's like oh you no welcome to the
start of the race now now it's time to
run you ready to run and like the work
starts especially true when it comes to
closing uh uh m&a it's like when you
have the op what a lot of people don't
realize is it it it takes from getting
the offer to actually getting the money
that can take six months that could take
for me it took they emailed me in they
emailed me in September or October I got
paid in February yeah exactly three
months six months is a very common and
so you um yeah that's the time to spit
the hardest the second thing he said was
he goes um show me your data room and I
was like oh uh we have a Google drive
but like it's kind of messy right now
and he goes um he goes you're selling
your company think of it like a product
on Amazon how does Amazon sell a product
I'm like there's like a page and a one
like a oneclick buy he goes exactly you
need to turn your entire company into a
giant buy button and I was like what is
that he's like you need to like answer
all the questions now get it all
organize now put it all in place now so
that when they look at this stuff they
are ready to oneclick buy if the more
questions they have to ask you the more
you have to go dig stuff up the more
half or incomplete information you have
uh to give them the more reasons that
this deal could fall apart turn your
company into a giant buy button that's
the other advice I've get given which is
like what are all the the Ducks I can
line up here so that this just becomes a
you know easy to understand easy to
consume uh you know process for them and
like it was the one you know 30-day
period of my life where I became Marie
condo I organized the [__] out of my
company I took everything I was like
look this need needs to be bulletproof
and uh I'm so glad that I did cuz it was
it was extremely necessary do you want
to do one last one yeah oh by the way I
have one never will I ever uh run my
company like a personal piggy bank so uh
I made this mistake before and I have a
story of a friend of ours who uh made
this mistake before so what a lot of
people do when they run their company is
you start to make some money and then
you're like oh I have to pay taxes and
then they're like [__] taxes suck and
you're like what can I do to like reduce
my spend it all like I think smart
people um smart people have like tax
stuff they do so what let me let me
start doing some tax stuff I like okay
what's the tax stuff and they're like oh
let me uh uh like we talked to a guy
recently that was like oh I created my
own captive insurance program and then I
bought this property that we're using as
like a office and I'm
like I what are you doing you're trying
to save like 200 Grand of taxes and what
you're doing is actually you're ruining
your books so like when I looked at his
business the business looked like it had
no profit and he's like you know so
happy that he's has this like shitty
margin shitty net profit margin because
in that year it saved them on taxes but
the reality is if you're building a
company that you want to sell you need
to take some short-term pain of having
clean simple books that you pay you know
legit taxes on in order for you to have
a big exit at the end because they're
going to see a track record of multiple
years of solid profits that that you're
going to sell in the end right like that
is just generally better there's of
course exceptions to both cases but like
generally that is a better approach we
have and if you don't want to sell
there's a there is like a [__]
category on QuickBooks that you could
put stuff into but that is not ideal if
you're trying to sell yeah exactly is if
you're trying to sell you want to you
want to be able to show a track record
of of success and uh versus like you
know I had a friend who would go to the
bank on December 30th and take out a
bunch of cashiers checks that they were
going to use to pay vendors and it's
like um prepay vendors for the next year
and then the next year they're like ah I
want to quit this vendor but I've
already prepaid them or they'll like
take two of the checks and never even
pay and put it back in the bank a month
later hope nobody notices it's like dude
just don't do this [__] like don't treat
your company like a personal piggy bank
if you want to sell this someday because
nobody wants to buy your hot mess and um
I think it's very and you can't undo
that you you can't really unwind that
these are like it's in the it's in the
history books every year that you're
doing that you are kind of like making
your you're adding a bunch of asteris to
your own books that like you need a
buyer who's willing to go and do a bunch
of ADB backs and try to figure this out
in order to feel confident that they
should buy this business when Dave poroy
sold you know he sold BARC Sports a
couple times but the first time he sold
it he was like I was an idiot he's like
I owned a racehorse that I bought
through barol Sports and so bar stool
Sports owed like two racehorses uh a
trailer for the racehorse uh they owned
like the house I was in like he said all
the stuff that the business owned and
he's like we got docked so hard 000 L of
Jin that we acquired like
yeah that's what he said he's like he's
like chin didn't want to buy like Skippy
the racehorse um but the business owned
it and we it was really hard you know
when he first sold that business he sold
the first portion of it and at the time
barol was a big deal he only sold it at
a $15 million valuation crazy when it
was worth way more than that and it's
probably because it was he was just
sloppy uh a lot of it was sloppy and he
was like I also like made so much profit
and I didn't put any of the profit back
into the company I just would buy horses
and [__] like that and gamble he's like
we gambled like crazy because it was
content um is that it I got one more
never will I ever just just stay at home
when there's a deal to be closed so this
is the rule of just get on a plane go
meet go meet people in person don't do
Zoom calls or if you're doing Zoom calls
add in the inperson afterwards
uh the in-person meetings are so
important um you know I'll I'll tell one
story which was uh just a deal we closed
recently
uh the you one deal that we didn't close
that I got on a plane for and like you
know for me I my the running joke on the
spot is I don't leave my house and it's
true I really don't leave my house I
don't like to do that I got little kids
and I don't know it's for our family
life it's very disruptive to travel if I
go if I leave the house for like five
days or whatever but I did for this one
deal it didn't the deal didn't go
through but I could sleep easy at night
cuz I'm like I did everything like I
made multiple offers on this deal I got
on the plane I met them in person like
you know we did everything that we could
we could do we did what was in our
control um with a deal that we just
recently did the other party was like
cool like after the initial conversation
of Interest they were like
cool uh would love to just next chat
would love to do it in person I'm happy
to fly out to you wherever you are let
me know which day works I'll fly in same
day fly out same day it it'll be easy um
and I was like I respect this person and
I trust doing business with this person
because they understand this principle
of like you just got to get on a plane
and you got to go meet somebody and you
should be willing to do that when we
sold the milk Road I had a similar
situation where we um remember I told
you about the high offer and the fair
offer we had said no to the fair offer
took the high offer then regretted it so
we went back to the fair offer months
later and we were like uh I was like you
know what I want to see what those guys
are up to and see if there's a deal to
be done here and uh I kind of called or
emailed and it was sort of like we just
had like a quick I texted I think and it
was like really wasn't an opening but I
was like hey I'm going to be in the city
tomorrow um you know for my niece's
soccer
game um so I was like I'll go see my
niece's soccer game but I'm gonna I'm
really doing this to meet you but I made
it sound to him like I was going to the
soccer game and I was like uh y we love
to catch up he's like yeah great let's
do it and so we drive into the city um
car breaks down on vaness and my car
literally just shuts off in the middle
of the road your car breaks down car
shut uh I don't know what happened the
car stopped stopped driving and I like
and the momentum to let me just get it
to the side of the road but I'm there
with my don't you have like a brand new
Escalade this is the BMW before that so
um this is you know I'm with my wife my
two kids are in the back in the car
seats car's broken down I got this
meeting in you know 10 minutes and
um I'm like [__] I guess I got to cancel
this meeting and whatever who like who
knows what if this meeting anything
would have even come of it anyways but
like whatever we'll wait for AAA and my
wife is like no you got to go you told
you've been telling me all morning how
this is an important meeting like you
think that you have a feeling that you
could be able to to get this deal back
on like you know go and um I was like
I'm just not g to leave my wife and kids
on vanest in San the middle of San
Francisco in a broke down car and she's
like just go we'll be fine I was like
okay you don't have to tell me twice and
so I hop out and uh I literally run
I I run down vanest like you know a mile
basically get to the coffee shop meet
the guy deal comes back to life by the
end of that coffee meeting and we ended
up selling to them and and I'm like I I
think I'm I'm actually like 100% sure if
I hadn't gone to that coffee meeting
that deals doesn't happen and um because
in that meeting we were able to clear up
some things that like were not as exact
transactional but like you know kind of
what his fears were and what our
hesitations were and really kind of sus
it out and get get comfortable with each
other in person so yeah insane insane
that that happened and uh this is like a
this is like an anti-ad for
BMW yeah don't trust them yeah don't
trust them they'll ruin your deals um
well that's sick um hopefully people dig
this we did a little Q&A for this
episode except on one topic I think
we're going to keep doing these every
other Tuesday right yeah we're trying to
come up with great topics that we can
kind of shoot the [__] on and share
maybe you know either our answers or uh
stories that that we've been through so
I think that's good I think people like
this one but let us know let us know in
the YouTube comments what you think all
right well well and there and that's the
pod